D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> THINGS ARE GOING TO GET
WORSE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ACCELERATION
OF THE NUMBER OF CASES, THE
SEVEN DAY AVERAGE HAS GONE UP
SUBSTANTIALLY.
>> AT WARRING FROM THOSE WITH
MAJOR HYPOCRITES AFTER A WEEKENN
RULES, WASHINGTON, D.C., ARIEL
BOWSER SPOTTED MASK WAS AT A
WEDDING AFTER SAVING THE CITY'S
MANDATE JUST HOURS BEFORE AND
CHICAGO
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT WHOSE
CELEBRITIES AFTER THREATENING
NEW COVID RESTRICTIONS.
SHE HAS ALSO BEEN CRITICIZED FOR
ALLOWING THAT MASK TO BE
DISCUSSED IN THE FIRST PLACE.
NEARLY 500 GUESTS HAVE BEEN
INVITED AND 200 WORKERS ARE
EXPECTED TO STAFF THE EVENT.
JUST TO GET A POINT ON THAT
JEN PSAKI THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY COMMENTED ON THE
PARTY, OBAMA PARTY, TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS BEEN A
HUGE ADVOCATE OF GETTING
VACCINATED AND THIS EVENT
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
REPORTING IS OUTDOORS AND
MODERATE TONE.
THE GUIDANCE IS THE STEPS PEOPLE
CAN TAKE WHEN A PUBLIC SETTING,
AND/OR SPECIFICALLY WITH THE NEW
GUIDANCE.
>> Dana: JESSE, DID YOU GET AN
INVITE?
>> Jesse: THE BIG STORY ABOUT
THAT IS THAT BARACK DID NOT
INVITE JOE.
[LAUGHTER]
NO, THEY WERE BEST BUDDIES FOR
EIGHT YEARS.
I COULD SEE TRUMP NOT BEING
ATTENDED TO A BIRTHDAY PARTY BUT
NOT INVITING TO BARACK OBAMA'S
PARTY?
HE DOESN'T WANT ANYBODY MORE
POWERFUL THAN HE IS AT THE
PARTY.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
IF I HAD A BIRTHDAY PARTY WOULD
I INVITE HANNITY?
NO.
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY SUCKING UP
TO SEAN BUT TO ME.
THE OTHER THING I HAVE IS COVID
COORDINATOR AT THE PARTY.
>> Dana: THAT IS A NEW THING.
>> Jesse: SO WHAT ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO DO SHOE ERIC HOLDER
AND THE HEAD WITH THE
TEMPERATURE GONE?
YOU CAN GO, ERIC.
SNEEZE DOWNWIND?
IT'S LIKE A USELESS JOB AND THEY
PROBABLY MAKE MORE THAN I AM.
PEARL JAM'S?
BARACK DOESN'T LIKE PEARL JAM'S.
OF COURSE THEY ARE NOT BECAUSE
MICHELLE DOESN'T LIKE PEARL JAM.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
>> Greg: I LOVE HOW YOU WERE
ABLE TO PIVOTS BUT YOU WERE TO
PIVOT ON HER?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: PEARL JAM.
>> Greg: IT'S HER FAULT.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT OBAMA
HASN'T BEEN OUT THERE SAYING PUT
MASKS ON.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY POWER NOW.
I'M VACCINATED, MY FRIENDS ARE
VACCINATED, I'M THROWING A
PARTY.
ISN'T THAT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING QUESTION WHAT >> Greg:
HAS COME I'M GOING TO TAKE THIS
AS HE'S A LEADER.
HE'S TELLING AMERICANS, IT IS
TIME.
COVID IS OVER AND SO WAS CLIMATE
CHANGE, RIGHT?
BETWEEN 500-700 PEOPLE, HOW MANY
PRIVATE JETS WILL BE LANDED IN
THE AIRPORT.
WE KNOW DO NOT FLIP THE LAST
COVID, THE THREATS OF DOOM KEEP
YOU FROM YOUR 60TH BIRTHDAY
PARTY.
I'M TOTALLY FOR IT, BUT I JUST
THINK IT'S LIKE WHITE?
PRESIDENT OBAMA, DOES HE STILL
NEED MORE LOVE?
HEY, THINK ABOUT ALL THE
CELEBRITIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
THERE.
IT IS JUST GOING TO BE
HILARIOUS.
>> Dana: ALONG WITH JESSE.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT GOING...
TUCKER IS GOING.
>> Dana: LORI LIGHTFOOT TO
SOME EXTENT BUT WE HAVE SEEN
THIS MOVIE BEFORE.
>> Greg: SHE MADE THE DEADLINE
AFTER THE WEDDING LIKE WE
WEREN'T SUPPOSED TO NOTICE THAT.
AND IT USED TO BE THAT LAWS WERE
FOR EVERYONE BUT NOT SO MUCH
ANYMORE.
WE ONLY HAVE LAW FOR THE
LAW-ABIDING.
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THIS?
WE DON'T HAVE ANY LAWS ANYMORE
WHERE PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED
THEM MEANING THE CRIMINALS AND
POLITICIANS.
SO WHEN THERE IS A SURGE IN
CRIME, THE INSTINCT IS TO GO
AFTER THE CRIMINAL IF COMMON
SENSE, BUT INSTEAD, THEY TALK
ABOUT CREATING MORE LAWS FOR GUN
CRIME, FOR BASICALLY LAWS THAT
WOULD BE FOLLOWED BY THE
LAW-ABIDING.
SO THE SUGGESTIONS AND
EVERYTHING WE HEAR IN THE ORDER
THAT WE ARE GIVEN, THEY ARE FOR
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW WILL DO THE
RIGHT THING.
BUT NO ONE EVER PRESSURES THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE WRONG
THING TO DO THE RIGHT.
POLITICIANS AND CRIMINALS, NO
DIFFERENT.
>> Jesse: THE MOVE AT THAT
WEDDING, GREG IS TO HAVE ALWAYS
A DRINK IN YOUR HAND.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW,
RICHARD, WHAT DID YOU THINK
ABOUT THE CC SCANDAL DOES YOUR?
>> Dana: I'VE I LIKE THE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM AND IT'S
RATHER FUNNY.
I THINK THE MAYOR, SHE SAID THAT
SHE HAD A MASK ON THE WHOLE TIME
BUT PEOPLE SHOW A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
>> Dana: THE SOCIAL MEDIA
TEAM...
>> Richard: I WOULD BE PRETTY
UPSET ALSO SO.
BUT LISTEN, I'M NOT A FAN OF
MAYOR de BLASIO, BUT I THINK
IT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT.
WHAT HE SAID TODAY WAS, LOOK, I
ASKED STRONGLY ENCOURAGE FOLKS
THAT ARE VACCINATED TO WEAR A
MASK INDOORS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF VARIANT BUT I
WILL NOT PUT OUT A MASK MANDATE.
THAT IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
FOLKS TO GET VACCINATED, WHICH
IS WHAT THE GOAL IS, TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
HAD A WEEK WHO REPORTED HIGHEST
NUMBER OF COVID CASES IN A
SINGLE DAY IN THE ENTIRETY OF
THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALSO KNOW THERE IS 10,000
PEOPLE IN FLORIDA OVER THAT THAT
ARE CURRENTLY HOSPITALIZED.
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP THIS IS
VACCINATION AND UNDERSTANDING
THE VACCINATION IS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN THE COVID
TREATMENT IF YOU CATCH COVID AND
YOU END UP BEING HOSPITALIZED.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO IT WITH A
CARROT AND NOT A STICK.
>> Dana: VACCINATIONS ARE UP.
THEY MET THE DEADLINE.
70% OF THE FIRST SHOT BY
JULY 1ST, AUGUST 1ST.
>> WE ARE MEETING THOSE GOALS
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAY
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE BEING
CONTROLLED AND THE KIDS GOING
BACK TO SCHOOL AND THAT KIDS BE
MASSED, THE PANIC PUSHERS ON
COVID ARE NOT AFRAID OF COVID
COME APPARENTLY.
PEOPLE LIKE MAYOR BOWSER OR
GAVIN NEWSOM IN CALIFORNIA,
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN AFRAID OF
THIS IN A WAY THEY ARE PUSHING
EVERYBODY ELSE AND ACTING THAT
EVERYBODY IS TERRIFIED ABOUT IT.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY NOT?
IF IT IS AS SERIOUS AS THEY ARE
SAYING WITH EVERY ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES, YOU WOULD THINK
THEY WOULD BE TAKING IT SERIOUS,
BUT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY.
IT WAS MORE IMPORTANT TO HANG
OUT WITH PEOPLE AT THE WEDDING.
AND THEN A REPORTER, SHE WAS NOT
INVITED AND HOW DARE SHE REPORT
THE NEWS.
WHEN THERE ARE BIG DECISIONS
BEING MADE BY THE CDC DIRECTOR,
BY THE WHITE HOUSE DIRECTOR IN
THE WHITE HOUSE TOP COVID
ADVISORS TODAY WHO IS FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA SANG THE
MASTS THAT WE ARE WEARING, AND
95 MASKS ARE NOT WORKING TOO
SLOW THE SPREAD.
WHEN THEY PUT THE GOVERNMENT
MANDATES IN PLACE WITH SMALL
BUSINESSES OR CORPORATIONS TO DO
THE SAME, YOU ARE AFFECTING
PEOPLE'S LIVES, LIVELIHOOD, AND
KIDS TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL WITH
SOCIAL INTERACTION WITH EACH
OTHER.
SO I THINK IT IS A BIGGER
QUESTION OF, WHY ARE THEY ACTING
LIKE EVERYBODY NEEDS TO PANIC
AND POSSIBLY LOCKED DOWN AGAIN
AND DO ALL THESE THINGS WHEN
THEY ARE NOT DOING THEM AND
IMPLEMENTING RULES THAT NONE OF
THEM ARE AFFECTED BY IT?
THE PEOPLE THAT GO TO
BARACK OBAMA'S BIRTHDAY PARTY
ARE NOT AFFECTED BY THESE RULES.
THEY CAN FLY ON A PRIVATE JET,
HAVE THINGS DELIVER TO COME ALL
THE PEOPLE MANDATING THESE
ISSUES SKIRT THE RULES ARE NOT A
FIGHT STOMACH AFFECTED BY IT.
>> Greg: IT IS AN INTERESTING
KIND OF CLASS WARFARE IN A SENSE
THAT YOU CAN TELL PEOPLE TO DO
THE THINGS THAT YOU, YOUR CELL
CAN ENDURE, BUT THEY CAN'T AND
OVER TIME, THEIR LIVES GET
WORSE.
AND I EVEN PUT MYSELF IN THE
EXCEPTION.
I WAS ABLE TO WALK ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THIS.
WE WERE ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME
AND THAT'S WHY WE WANTED TO GET
BACK HERE.
WE ARE GIVING ADVICE TO PEOPLE
AND YET, WE ARE NOT TAKING THE
ADVICE.
>> Dana: IT IS DIFFERENT THAN
A RESTAURANT ON HER WHO GOT
THROUGH THIS AND I'LL LOOKING AT
THE POSSIBILITY OF -- TODAY,
THEY SAID THERE MIGHT BE MORE
RESTRICTIONS COME IN.
THE >> Richard: I THINK WHAT
THE CDC SAID IS THERE IS A HIGH
INFECTION RATE AND LOW
VACCINATION RATE.
HERE IS THE THRESHOLD, WHEN YOU
GET TO THIS POINT YOU HAVE TO GO
TO MASKING AND TO THIS POINT,
LOCKED DOWN EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT
THAT THRESHOLD IS AND SO PEOPLE
AREN'T AN ALERT WHEN SOMETHING
COMES OUT FROM THE CDC.
>> Jesse: IT'S NOT CLEAR.
ACCORDING TO THOSE GUIDELINES
COME EVERY SINGLE CITY RIGHT
NOW, YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK
ACCO